[Dripping tap, buzzing sound]
When I was pregnant, I was small, my economic situation was difficult, and I was dating this man who would call him Dick.
I met with you when I was working on a TV show
I remember entering the studio when I felt awe
I watched actors and actresses take their places before shooting began
I had left the community college classes that absorbed my soul back and went to a real photography site
Hi hello. I'm here for the background. I apologize if you're late
D: Everything's fine I'm a dick
A: Hi Anna "Anna"
romantic music
A: I was honored to meet you
D: If I just wait here a few, your turn will come soon
A: Well
Exciting music
D: I'm on my way
Good Morning A: With safety
D: Oh wait a little
D: I've done a great job today. Thanks
D: Do you want to work on this offer again?
I love working in the background
I bought my groceries from the 99 fils store
I wanted all the jobs and all the free hot meals I could get
You have a digital application to book me work directly, and every week call me to show me a job
I loved it, and one day when I was getting ready to go out
[Sparks voice]
I did not know that this was on the table. If he flirts with me
It did not take long before you sent intensive messages to you
[Send Message]
I imagined his body under his loose clothes.
Then I discovered D: My brother died
A: I'm sorry since I lost my sister as well
Immediately a novel was invented by Rammansia
A: Two survivors, we are destined to be together,
D: We can help each other heal
A: In my imagination, we had a deep connection
No one else can understand
A: We had a common grief
the death
You are crazy people, you bother too much
[Sounds off the screen]
Finally, surrendered
During a dinner, I knew he loved meditation and loved the outdoors
He believes in pluralism
I asked him to explain
D: Unilateralism is an outdated concept that no one can support
I'm like most idiots I thought he just did not meet the right person yet
I and Dick met us for a year and a half and every three months, he betrayed me
Knock on the door
Every three months, he confesses his betrayal and apologizes
He was saying that his behavior was due to the suicide of his brother, and that this incident left him a damaged makkuro
I thought to myself that I could see what he was going through
I discovered the passcode for his phone, and I waited until he drowned in sleep, and read his messages
He was angry because I had violated his privacy, and the cycle was over
Despite these very clear red signals, we stayed together,
During this period
get pregnant
I was not committed to taking birth control pills
I used to do four jobs, attend comedy sessions, acting classes, and shoot weekly videos
I used to go to sleep late at night and wake up early, often forgetting to take the pill
I will not bear, I have lost my sister, but surely the Creator will give me a break
One morning, Helmtay's feeling was strange
[Shower running]
I knew immediately
Music
Smiley face? Smiley face. Smiley face stupid.
D: What is this?
D: This is not a good time for me to have a baby and you should be great
You do not want to have a child, you have to be much bigger
Look. He answers that you raise this child with another man
A: He seriously told me that I should meet her baby with another man
D: You have to abort this child
A: At least answer that we have a conversation about it
D: Any conversation?
I will not abort this child, at least answer that we talk about ...
[Sudden silence, then sad music]
I spent years secretly secretly judging my friends who aborted
How can they destroy such a life?
I thought they were human beings
But of course, when this happens to you, check yourself
Am I ready to correct either? No
Are you ready to become a father? No
Do I have the economic ability to support a child
No, I hardly have the ability to feed 3 cats
Eventually she reached the same conclusion as Dick
They told me that I was only seven days pregnant.
The doctor was very impressed when I told him the story of the nipples.
Doc: I'm very impressed with the story of nipples
A: Thanks
Doctor: Oops
Abortion pills were given.
Unless the doctor tells me about the pill, Houghthian.
Well, Um, I'm pregnant.
I'll admit that I like people to think I'm pregnant.
He made me want to walk around with my big belly and the way people would treat me
Each tube will open to me
Maybe people will offer me something to eat
I imagined I was nine months pregnant with my child
I wanted only one thing to make it easier for me to do this
Someone who truly loves me
I knew then that I wanted to be a mother, but this was not the right time
If you bring a child in the world,
I want to be able to give it both my love and attention.
I want to be in a relationship where the child is loved
[Running water]
I bleed, cried and screamed for three hours
I wondered if I was doing the right thing, if this was killed.
If you are a bad person
I promised myself that I would not do this again
When I carry the next time I will be ready
[Anna sigh, the sound of the bell]
[Voice Message]
D: Darling, did you think how you would pay me half the amount of abortion?
I hope to say my relationship with you and your dick has ended there, but we have not
I still thought you had a spiritual companion.
He was the only person who could understand what you ordered him, and vice versa.
I liked his smell, the color of his eyes, took me to Buddhist meditation sessions
It was the reason I was swallowed up in a week of silence
I spent seven hard days sitting with myself, walking with myself, and living with myself.
On the last day of silence, we all had to walk around and say one word summarizing our experience.
Love
Full
exploration
Super-cali-fragilistic-expialidocious.
Laughter
I discovered
this is me
I am someone who makes others laugh.
I felt peace, I love myself without shame, or neurosis, or arrogance.
When I feel the most calm, a loving moment of life in my life,
Dick was entering his penis in someone else
When he appeared in my door crying and begging for forgiveness,
Finally I thought, Damn this man.
In the desert, I finally found some self-esteem.
I have not been pregnant since.
Translation: GEX